ahora aprendamos un poco sobre fluidos
es muy probable que ustedes tengan ya
alguna idea al respecto un fluido es
cualquier cosa que toma la forma de lo
que lo contiene Por ejemplo si yo tengo
una esfera de vidrio completamente llena
de agua Aunque mejor digamos que es una
esfera de plástico Si yo fuera a cambiar
la forma de la Esfera y se viera
así el agua cambiaría su forma al igual
que su contenedor y lo mismo sucedería
si esto fuera oxígeno o algún gas
llenaría el contenedor y se adaptaría a
la forma de
este entonces un
fluido es igual a que toma la forma del
contenedor Y tenemos dos tipos de
fluidos los
líquidos líquidos y los
gases al ser el gas comprimible aquí
pongo gas es
comprimible la diferencia con los
líquidos es que los líquidos
no se
pueden
comprimir como les decía al ser el gas
comprimible puedo reducir el volumen del
contenedor y el gas Se volverá más denso
en cambio los líquidos no se pueden
comprimir imaginen el mismo globo lleno
de agua si quisiéramos comprimir este
globo por todas partes al mismo tiempo
no podríamos reducir su volumen sin
importar que
hagamos en cambio Si este estuviera
lleno de
gas sí podríamos disminuir el volumen al
incrementar la presión en todos los
lados del globo y esta es la diferencia
entre un líquido y un gas ahora vamos a
enfocarnos un poco más en los líquidos
para aprender un poco más sobre el
movimiento de los líquidos y de ahí al
movimiento de los fluidos en general
vamos a limpiar la
pantalla ahora digamos que tenemos una
situación donde hay un contenedor de una
forma peculiar como este y que el área
de la primera abertura es a1 y el área
de la segunda abertura es
a2 llenemos este con algún
líquido más o menos así y recordemos que
los líquidos no se pueden
comprimir ahora recordemos lo que
sabemos de trabajo y veamos si podemos
deducir algunas reglas de fuerza y
presion en los
líquidos recordemos que trabajo
W es fuerza por
distancia y de la ventaja mecánica
aprendimos que el trabajo de entrada es
igual al trabajo de salida
W = A
WS al trabajo de salida que viene de la
ley de la conservación de la energía
recordemos que la energía de entrada
será igual a la energía de salida debido
a que ninguna energía se crea o se
destruye solamente se transforma Así que
sustituimos esta fórmula del trabajo
aquí y tenemos fe fuerza de entrada por
la distancia de entrada es igual a la
fuerza de salida por la distancia de
salida ahora digamos que voy a comprimir
u oprimir a uno con cierta fuerza usando
algo así como un pistón más o menos así
dibujo el pistón Aquí está f1 que es con
lo que voy a oprimir este pistón y Esto
va a
bajar una distancia
uno así que bueno el pistón se desplaza
una distancia de uno y aquí Mi pregunta
es Cuánta agua se va a desplazar o cuál
es el volumen de agua que se desplazará
aquí en el área de
a2 el volumen desplazado
bd es igual a la distancia por el área
ya que bueno esta sección es como un
cilindro Así que
bd es igual a a1 por
D1 y recordemos que un líquido no puede
cambiar su volumen por lo que todo este
volumen se verá reflejado aumentando
algo el nivel de este otro lado Aquí
vamos a tener d2 que será el nuevo de
nivel en que será se elevará este
nivel Cómo sabemos la nueva distancia al
comprimir este lado de a1 se va a
recorrer todo el líquido y se va a
desplazar algo en el otro lado por lo
que el volumen que se desplazó en a1
será el mismo que se desplaza En a2 cuál
será ese cambio de volumen b2 igual a
distancia 2 por el área do Y de nuevo
recordamos que este líquido no se puede
comprimir por lo que el volumen es el
mismo así que tenemos
a1 * D1 = a a2 por d2 y también sabemos
que la fuerza que entra aquí es la
fuerza que sale pero se nos acaba el
tiempo nos vemos en el próximo
video